[Music]
it's
incredible you
live you die it's the in between it
[Applause]
counts I got a proposition for you need
you to take my boat out for a run yeah
okay
pop Tom I was wondering maybe you need
an extra deck hand my brother I'm
curious curious about what about me
about you too
maybe we're going to show you what real
fishermen can do we're going some
Canadian
Waters what happens if you get caught I
got a
new getting caught is not an
option Canadian Coast
Guard your vessel's been
seized if I got a $100,000 fine I'm
going to lose my father's boat now the
I never should have trusted you I do not
understand the way you're built you
built me
a I can't help you you're going to have
to do just what I ask you
to I like my resources we want to do
business well Maybel here said you guys
are one time and but if this works out
this is it one time
[Music]
only do you know what line you're
crossing right now
I she set us
[Music]
up you
live you
[Music]
die it's the in between that
counts do and it's going
[Music]
over